les autorités de la république
démocratique du congo viennent
officiellement de confirmer la mort de
laurent désiré kabila c'est le fils du
président tué mardi à kinshasa qui
semble avoir pris la tête du
gouvernement
les circonstances de la mort de laurent
désiré kabila reste encore très mal
définie à kinshasa la capitale
congolaise où se trouve notre envoyé
spécial eric monier la situation est
calme commentaires bernard lebrun après
48 heures d'incertitude c'est désormais
officiel laurent désiré kabila 61 ans a
succombé à ses blessures
pour autant les 43 millions de congolais
attendent toujours que sa mort leur soit
annoncé à la télévision
gagner du temps pour installer réimposer
au pouvoir le jeune joseph kabila 31 ans
c'est ce qu'ont voulu les autorités le
fils du président défunt a reçu hier
soir les diplomates en poste à kinshasa
dont les ambassadeurs de france et de
belgique
la dépouille mortelle du président se
trouverait dans un hôpital à harare où
seraient aussi rassembler une grande
partie de la famille kabila de source
diplomatique belge et sud africaines
le corps du président serait transférée
dès demain à lubumbashi capitale du
katanga et ville natale de laurent
désiré kabila puis dimanche il serait
ramené à kinshasa où des funérailles
nationales n'auront lieu que mardi 23
janvier kinshasa où la situation demeure
très calme pour l'instant
et les commerces ont ouvert normalement
aujourd'hui les gens sont allés
travailler normalement
l'ambiance est particulière et
singulière parce que la mort de laurent
désiré kabila est un secret de
polichinelle et les kinois ont taxé au
aux médias internationaux et donc savent
très bien que le président est décédé
mais cette mort n'a pas été
officiellement annoncée donc il n'y a
pas encore de deuil qui est organisée ou
de manifestation quelconque ce soir
d'aidé officielle devrait s'exprimer à
la télévision pour annoncer la mort du
président congolais
en attendant l'opposition en exil au
régime de kabila se manifeste déjà pour
réclamer des élections et contester la
succession sonos inde là où il veut mais
ça me dit absolument rien du tout
contrairement aux annonces officielles
le ferry entre brazzaville et kinshasa
est resté à quai aujourd'hui mais le
trafic aérien lui a pu reprendre